[Music]
how's it going bros my name
is welcome to SCP B I played the first
one it was honestly a piece of [__] a
piece of [__] anyway SCP which of course
stands for secure contain and
penetrate uh this is supposed to
actually be well now entering SCP 087 B
please proceed with caution caution no I
don't want to I'm sick of the [__]
test just let me get out of here please
please you said it was just you said it
would be candies no there was a fat man
he was in a van he said you come here
and you will get candies and I okay want
the candies I guess the candies oh I
went backwards all right that's
a
ah so there's corridors now apparently
instead of stairs what well what oh
there is stairs lovely welcome to
Corridor and staircase simulator
2012 this is [__] creepy as here all
right I am on floor two can I make it to
floor
5 is there something there hello
hello who's
breathing hello shut up
Dad
uh it's fine your breath can't do [__]
on Me Breath can never kill
me unless it's really disgusting and yes
but smell it it is seriously have you
considering taking a mint
hello I just want the candies all right
I'm sure there's a lot of goodies down
here
hello no what that hello
I don't like the random noises make him
stop ah [__] it we're going to do this
am I walking backwards again yes I am
God damn I'm a [__] can you run in
this game you
can okay oh they right I don't like this
game I don't like I just I just said
candies
oh my God okay we're just going to keep
[Music]
going is anyone there mom is that you
momy you're not funny I don't like
[Music]
this okay I get
it
hello is anybody
here please don't kill me I'm sorry the
joke I made about your breath I didn't
mean to do
it it was the barrels maybe the barrels
are behind
us now that I think about it the boy the
the man I was talking to he sort of
looked like a
barrel oh they disguised themselves to
put me here those [__]
Barrel God damn
it I knew it I [__] knew it
all right we're just going to get
through
this I'm swimming around in that Vina
I'm swimming around in a vagina I'm
swimming around in the corridor I try to
make a princess I'm swimming around in a
vagina singing helps actually it's
pretty nice I'm swimming around in a
vagina I'm swimming around in a corridor
I try to not share get my pants actually
I already did
it is anyone there I was just kidding ah
[__] me I always go
backwards the floor 13 oh snap
hello is there someone
there
okay I'm playing on my laptop by the way
I don't know if I said it can't get this
game work for whatever reason on my
desktop Tri a little different than
[Music]
what okay I didn't do anything I swear
it wasn't me I swear it
was ah [__] me I'm walking backwards
again I suck at this game if this game
had an objective I'm [__] failing at
it
ah I see
you okay it didn't work Dre ball I see
double quad are you there no all right
fine am I walking backwards again I oh
God it's
okay this is why I they put me through
training cuz I'm not very good at
walking straight but they made
a stop with your [__] breath it
smells like anchovies I don't like
anchovies they are actually good if you
fry them a little bit and I don't know I
like to stick them in other people's
mouth when they're asleep
that's what I do people keep asking hey
what do you do I put UN shs in people's
mouth you got a problem with that [__]
and then you just give me a face like
like that I'm
like oh oh I knew it isone
there okay I'm just going to go over
here
then oh I keep going backwards I see you
ah okay I didn't see anyone
a okay he's not behind me he's a liar I
don't appreciate lying
people all right we can do this Bros I
think the maximum is 50 floors 50
million so it's
okay hello Mom are you doing this Mom
you said there would be
candies
mom [__] that's
liar she said to will be a lot of
delicious streets that sounds pretty
disgusting though okay let's just keep
focusing on the stair walking see if I
can actually get myself through this
better
what he's wearing a baby suit oh
oh look at this one he's wearing a b
he's so cute look at that oh I just want
to oh look it's me it's me two seconds
ago
ah oh look at this one he's like I'm
going to kill everyone oh I'm going to
kill
you oh this one is going to kill
everyone too it's fluffy he destroy of
words
oh oh look this one
no this is AD look it's
me
awesome okay one packing you can clean
up I'm done
oh you're hamster I ateed it all right
anyway I'm going to end it here Bros
hope you enjoyed like and favorite if
you did subscribe to K today oh look at
this
swood snake cat has bited before snake
cat will bite again oh no okay anyway
I'm going to end
here